Tu as entre 15 et 18 ans, tu vas au lycée, et comme la plupart des jeunes de ton âge, tu écoutes du rap.
Jusque-là, rien d'anormal.
Tu es adolescent, tu es à un âge où on a besoin de s'identifier à des figures rebelles pour pouvoir construire son identité.
Donc écouter des paroles vulgaires ou pseudo-révolutionnaires sur de la grosse rythmique, à ton âge, c'est cohérent...
Seulement voilà le problème : tu écoutes du rap et à côté de cela, quand tu es en cours de français,
tu t'emmerdes et tu trouves ça sans intérêt.
La littérature, les figures de style, l'analyse de texte...
Tout cela, ce n'est pas ton truc. Et c'est là qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas.
Parce qu'aimer le rap et ne pas aimer le français, ce n'est pas compatible.
Tu ne peux pas aimer le rap et ne pas t'intéresser aux français, parce que le rap, c'est du français.
Le rap, c'est du langage, c'est le maniement des mots, c'est sculpter le verbe pour faire naître des images et des impressions.
C'est le principe même de la poésie : jouer sur les possibilités qu'offre la langue pour véhiculer des idées ou transmettre des émotions.
Donc quand tu écoutes du rap, tu écoutes un texte qui a été précisément écrit pour produire tel effet à tel moment.
Tu écoutes
une œuvre littéraire.
Et pour te convaincre, je me suis dit que le mieux était de te le prouver dans cette vidéo.
Je suis donc allé chercher sept
procédés littéraires dans les chansons d'une référence en matière de rap : Booba.
Booba est sans doute l'un des rappeurs français les plus adeptes des figures littéraires.
Quoi qu'on pense du personnage, le fait est qu'on trouve dans ses textes toute la panoplie des procédés littéraires qu'on étudie en français au lycée.
Si après cette vidéo tu trouves toujours que l'étude du français n'a aucun intérêt quand on aime le rap,
alors je suis désolé de te le dire, c'est que tu ne connais rien au rap.
Donc voilà comment ça va se passer : je vais passer plusieurs extraits et on va analyser ensemble les procédés qu'ils contiennent.
Tu es prêt ?
Alors c'est parti !
Alors, quel est le procédé utilisé ici ?
Si tu ne vois pas, demande-toi si tu as déjà vu des paroles avec des menottes aux poignets.
En effet, les paroles n'ont pas de poignets.
Elles n'ont pas de poignets car elles n'ont pas de corps, car elles ne sont pas des
personnes.
La figure de style utilisée ici est la personnification. C'est quand on décrit une chose on lui attribuant des caractéristiques humaines.
Parler de paroles ayant les menottes, cela peut signifier que le message que transmet Booba fait l'objet d'une censure ou qu'on l'empêche de s'exprimer librement.
Cela peut aussi signifier que ses paroles sont le reflet d'une violence qu'il exprime à travers l'exemple d'une arrestation policière
Bien sûr, personne n'est dans la tête de Booba pour vérifier que c'est bien cette signification-là et pas une autre qu'il a voulu
donner à sa phrase. Mais un procédé littéraire n'a pas besoin d'être volontaire pour être techniquement valable. Retiens ça.
Si on écoute ce refrain sans faire attention, on pourrait croire que Booba parle tout simplement de la femme qu'il aime.
D'ailleurs le titre "Tombé pour elle" est une référence explicite à la chanson de Pascal Obispo,
dans laquelle le chanteur déclare son amour pour une femme.
* Je suis tombé pour elle.
Je n'ai d'yeux que pour elle. *
Mais en réalité, quand on écoute la première phrase du refrain, on s'aperçoit que Booba ne fait pas référence à une femme, mais à la rue.
C'est la rue qui est ici personnifiée.
C'est donc l'amour de la rue qu'exprime Booba dans ce refrain, en jouant sur l'ambiguïté pour créer une image décalée et surprenante.
Il y a une autre figure de style qui permet de s'exprimer à partir d'images,
c'est la métaphore.
La métaphore est une comparaison sans outil de comparaison.
Elle consiste à remplacer ce dont on parle par autre chose afin de mettre en avant l'un de ses aspects.
Exemple de métaphore :
En comparant le corps d'une femme à un coffre-fort, Booba souligne son caractère précieux. C'est une manière d'exprimer
l'intensité de son attirance pour elle. De plus, en déclarant vouloir s'emparer de ce coffre-fort,
Booba insinue qu'il veut séduire cette femme à la manière d'un cambrioleur ou d'un braqueur de banque : voler son cœur pour en être l'unique propriétaire.
Tu trouves que ça va trop loin ? Ecoute bien :
Que remarques-tu ? Tu remarques que Booba prolonge sa métaphore du coffre-fort dans les vers suivants,
en évoquant les codes de sécurité et en parlant d'"effraction", qui désigne le fait de pénétrer dans un lieu sans en avoir l'autorisation.
On appelle ça une métaphore filée. C'est une métaphore qui se poursuit sur plusieurs lignes.
Personnification, comparaison, métaphore... Toutes ces figures de style ont un trait en commun : elles fonctionnent sur le principe de l'analogie.
L'analogie consiste à faire un parallèle avec une situation sans rapport mais
qui a un rapport.
Par exemple, si je te dis que le rap, c'est de la boxe avec des rimes à la place des poings,
tu comprends l'idée.
Tu sais très bien que le rap et la boxe n'ont rien à voir, mais tu saisis la comparaison.
C'est ça une analogie.
L'analogie est un procédé très efficace pour produire des images qui parlent à l'esprit. On utilise l'analogie pour décrire une situation
sans avoir besoin de passer par de longues phrases d'explication.
Elle peut également créer un effet comique lorsque les deux choses mises en relation appartiennent à des univers totalement différents.
Quelques exemples :
Dans le rap, il y a deux sortes de figures de style qu'on retrouve souvent en raison de leur efficacité :
les figures d'analogie, on vient d'en voir quelques-unes, et les figures d'opposition.
Parmi les figures d'opposition, la plus connue est l'antithèse.
L'antithèse, c'est lorsque l'auteur établit une opposition entre deux idées contraires.
Les rappeurs ont souvent recours à ce procédé pour exprimer le fait qu'ils sont
en révolte contre le monde, contre les règles, les institutions.
Chez Booba, ça peut donner ça par exemple :
L'antithèse peut aussi servir à souligner un paradoxe, à renforcer un contraste ou à créer un décalage comique.
L'antithèse se marie très bien avec une autre figure de style qu'on appelle le parallélisme.
Le parallélisme consiste à juxtaposer deux propositions ayant la même structure grammaticale.
Exemple :
C'est une manière de renforcer l'antithèse en créant une impression de répétition.
C'est un procédé très utilisé dans la publicité
parce qu'il permet de créer des formules-slogans : des phrases qui nous restent dans la tête et qu'on n'arrive plus à effacer.
Si Booba est devenu une sorte de chef d'orchestre de la "punchline",
ce n'est pas seulement en raison de son recours fréquent aux figures de style.
C'est aussi grâce à son sens du rythme et de la musicalité des mots.
Le rap de Booba est très axé sur les sonorités et la prononciation.
On entend les mots davantage qu'on ne les comprend. C'est une caractéristique de la poésie.
Le texte n'est pas simplement fait pour être lu,
il est aussi fait pour être entendu.
Le maniement des sons fait donc partie intégrante des procédés poétiques. Et parmi les procédés poétiques,
il y en a un que tous les chanteurs ont l'obligation de connaître.
C'est la diérèse. La diérèse, c'est le fait de prononcer "di-é-rèse" au lieu de prononcer "dié-rèse".
C'est une manière d'étirer le mot pour gagner une syllabe dans le vers et respecter ainsi la rythmique.
Et chez Booba, la diérèse, c'est... récurrent.
Dans chacun de ces extraits, on a l'impression que toutes les diérèses ont été voulues par Booba,
comme si le mot plus long avait juste servi de prétexte
pour étirer les autres.
Le jeu sur les sonorités, on le retrouve aussi dans ce qu'on appelle la paranomase.
La paronomase, c'est le fait d'utiliser des mots proches au niveau sonore pour créer une impression de fluidité
ou de répétition. Là encore, l'idée est qu'on peut transmettre plus de choses par le son des mots que par leur sens.
Par exemple :
Un autre procédé qui consiste à jouer sur le son des mots est l'allitération.
L'allitération est la répétition d'un même son consonne, comme dans ce célèbre vers de Racine :
Le son [s] est répété pour suggérer phonétiquement le sifflement du serpent.
Chez Booba, ça pourra donner :
Sans qu'on s'en aperçoive, Booba a inséré une allitération dans ces deux vers.
Le son de la lettre "V" se répète, comme pour mieux suggérer l'idée du vent qui porterait la plume.
Le son vient ici renforcer l'idée exprimée dans les paroles.
Encore une fois la question n'est pas de savoir si Booba utilise ces procédés volontairement ou inconsciemment.
La question est de savoir si ces procédés sont bel et bien présents dans ses textes.
Et la réponse est oui.
Quelle que soit notre opinion sur le rap, force est de constater qu'il s'agit d'une des dernières passerelles entre la jeunesse et l'univers des lettres.
Et même si je ne vois pas forcément d'un bon œil le fait qu'on étudie les chansons de Diam's au lycée, je pense malgré tout
que cela peut constituer un levier,
imparfait mais nécessaire, à la reconnexion des jeunes avec la culture.
Cela n'a aucun sens de vouloir comparer Booba à Paul Valéry, Baudelaire ou Rimbaud.
Cela n'a aucun intérêt de se demander si les rappeurs sont les nouveaux poètes.
L'important est de comprendre qu'on n'a pas besoin d'être écrivain, poète ou chanteur pour jouer avec les subtilités de la langue française.
Et que plus tu maîtriseras ta langue, plus tu sauras exprimer de choses.
C'est ça l'intérêt du français : apprendre à dire et apprendre à entendre.
Merci d'avoir suivi cet épisode.
Abonnez-vous et partagez la vidéo si elle vous a plu.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la page Facebook "Le Précepteur".
Et un grand merci à tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur Tipeee,
vous me donnez du courage et de la motivation.
Je vous dis à bientôt pour un prochain épisode.
On lit ou on écrit de la poésie non pas parce que c'est joli.
On lit et on écrit de la poésie parce que l'on fait partie de l'humanité et que l'humanité est faite de passion.